(upbeat music)
(music)
- How many of you guys remember
the scene that happened
right here? What episode was that?
- [RECEPTIONIST] Here you are.
- Thank you.
- [RECEPTIONIST] You're Welcome
(music)
- [WOMAN] Hi Gary!
- [GARY] How are you? Good to see you.
- Nice to meet you. Hi!
(inaudible)
- [WOMAN] Lead by example, do better
- [GARY] All internal right?
- Yeah, all internal.
[GARY] From a global perspective.
- No, If you're happy with
it, so Westin Reeves just
tweeted "how can I get a signed
book without buying one off
ebay?". I just replied,
let me make sure to get
the exact reply, because I just replied,
I know what I wrote
You just got one, Garrett
Green works with me
and works with Tyler,
is now gonna get one,
I'm gonna come in the
office, we'll film it,
I'm gonna sign it, we're gonna send it,
and I'm gonna post this
video so everyone of you
understand, that scaling the
unscalable and going deep
and living the thank you
economy, my secret best book,
matters, because, it just does.
Just doing the right thing
works. It works in a way
that's hidden, I don't
know what the ROI of Westin
means to me for the rest of
my life, I don't know if this
forty-four dollar execution,
is gonna return me money
I know that putting that into
the ecosystem is gonna bring
value, will Westin tell that
story 4-5 times? Probably.
Heck, I do it all the time
but now I made this piece of
content that may inspire -doing
the right thing is the right
thing these are customers,
these are people that are
advocates, these are people
that give a crap about what you
or your business do and we
do not treat them with the
respect and the gratitude and
the empathy that they deserve
and thus our actions in
marketing don't reflect that
and we leave enormous amounts
of long term brand building
value on the table, in
exchange for short term sales
tactics.
(music)
- By the way great job
Garrett, 19 seconds and "boom"
jumped in ready.
And Westin right back
now, you're the man Gary,
I appreciate you. -and 4-5
people already asking for
another book too.
Put that whole little part
at the end, as a..yeah
not in it. After we ended
-you know the *beep*you know
- Hi. Thank you for coming.
- Thanks for having me.
(music)
- You know what I'll jump
in there I don't think I'm
three years ahead, I
just think I'm, today.
I genuinely believe that,
by the way and I think its
because of reporting or the
politics within an organization
I think I bring -If I look
at the these last five years
that I've run my agency and the
work we've done with biggest
brains in the world is its just
and entrepreneurial mindset
you know I think you need to
make -you need to walk in with
naive eyes to everything.
So, my big theory is I try to
put myself out of business
everyday, bless you, the things
that I'm passionate about
Facebook, Influencers, Instagram
for the wide brands-Snapchat,
I could care less if they go
out of business tomorrow, right,
I have no emotional ties to
anything, I don't see any vested
interests in the long term
for what worked for me 3
years ago, to work for me now
the process of driving down
creative costs, but not giving
up quality, by the way,
quality is subjective, you know
but, its perception, when you
pay for something its what you
deem its value, you don't value
the video I wanna make for
you for 37 thousand the same
as your above the line creative
agency charges you for 540
even if it was the same exact
thing. That's how humans roll
what's interesting is,
there's an appetite to not be
romantic
and that is a mindset that is
extremely attractive and much
needed, you can't be tied to
anything right now its just
moving too fast.
- Speaking of moving fast
you've gotta go to London.
- Yeah, see ya, Thank you!
(audience claps)
(music)
- You know I think that
obviously, I am out and about
in a very significant way, and
so would bring awareness to
it in general, outside recurring
clients for Vayner which
will be a gateway to this
opportunity, also I have a lot of
people, you know, through my
own vlogging that follow me
filmmakers and things of that
nature on YouTube and other
platforms that will probably
see this association and have
more, you know, I mean they
should already know we are
giving quality but, I think its
a brand play and a execution
play so obviously, you know,
I think one of the interesting
dynamics of how I saw this is,
I'm a big believer that you
have to always reverse engineer
what you are doing through
your client and so, as you
can imagine in this In this
if this structure executes the
video work instead of my own
production in-house capabilities,
I'm sharing the revenue
and that Is taking some
dollars out of my own pocket,
however, I always wanna
give my clients the best and
brightest options in every
scenario so I think the support
comes from awareness branding,
you know, being out there,
speaking to it and then
obviously being a very extremely
strong sales engine to the
opportunity and more importantly
helping a lot of these incredible
filmmakers understand the
nuances if they haven't worked
in the past with brands of
the creative freedoms and
some of maybe the limitations,
and so, being a handholding
process to the interpretation I
think could be to make it
go faster, smoother and more
successful, I think the thing
I've learned in building an
agency in a world where I
used to interact with them is
having that context brings a lot of value.
(rain sounds)
- 3:01 pm, big Shout out to
Sweet301 in Mount Ida College,
1994, you know how we did it (laughs)
Oh God!
Yeah no, I think there's a lot going on.
(pen sounds)
You didn't get it? Yeah so
that's how it is we don't need to
do a fucking fancy lets just
do it the way it actually is
and I don't know why we are
so overcomplicating it, I know
why I am, I'm not so sold why
I with some combination of you
guys, haven't figured this out.
For me as well I'm that one issue
I don't know, there's a million
people that work in new york
that do that.
But by the way that's exactly
the point, here's the best
part, I don't wanna make anybody
do anything, I do not wanna
meet Sally and you tell me to
convince her, that the right
path for her is to become a
unicorn, I'm done with unicorns
I only want one unicorn,
the guy that plays there,
that's it.
Boom, in the slot, go do your
thing, because then we can go
fast, then we know exactly what
their titles are there's no
confusion, now we layer the complications.
Everybody needs to get as far
as they can if you get 100%
alignment, you send me
something, that you say Is a 100%
alignment, I don't even open
the pdf, I say approved and we
all move fast.
That needs to be the framework
that this company works on
that is the magic, but we're
spending way too much time
debating with you guys when I'm
gonna make the ultimate call
anyway, right, like I'm gonna
sign off somewhere so what's
really smart is us all coming
to that reality, first of all
its better for you, its better
for me, we don't waste time
we enjoy our interactions on
moving the company because we
just know we're gonna do
everything that we get to agree on,
and then the parts we're not,
we're just gonna line item
them, we'll probably spend a
little more because we have
ambitions as being senior
people and try to get to that
place but I'm not, there's
gonna always be those things and
that's how we'll win.
- [GARY] Walk with us guys,
leave your kit-laptops here,
unless you need it, which
you can bring them too.
- Hey Katie!
- [GARY] What about -this
is ridiculous (laughs)
- You're speaking in New Orleans
the morning you are flying
CES, we can go private, its
looking like it might be about
22k I'm looking for a cheaper
one, you can go direct and
sooner but not first class
or you can connect Houston or
Dallas.
- Its first class?
- Yeah
- And I'll get there on time if I connect?
- You can land at like, 7:50
if you connect Firstclass,
its like 7 or 8 o'clock local Vegas time.
(music)
- Like I get credits for
things that I'm oblivious to,
do you know what I mean,
like just like that's a good
example like, people like,
think that I'm too cool (murmuring)
by the way this is of my
life, the only -the reason I
actually got girls to like me
in highschool was that I was
so into baseball cards, that
when they started liking me a
little more in my senior/junior
year, that I was A.scared of
them still, because I was maturing slowly.
And B. All I wanted to do was
build businesses that because
I wasn't reacting to them
like meh, it made them like me
more and its basically
what's happening in business
like people think that I'm
doing something because I am too
cool or I think its like,
but it -I'm just -that's the
whole part of it it is by
accident, it has always been by
accident, because if you do it
on purpose, the other person
can taste it, but they just,
they're equating it a little
different, they just think
I might be too busy or- its
actually just I'm- just, I don't know,
I did not follow *beep*
because, well actually maybe
then it is true, maybe because
I am so- maybe that actually is true,
now that I think about it
- Its the most genuine form of it
- (chuckles) yeah.
- [D ROCK] Do you wanna say something?
- Yes
- [D ROCK] No, more
- Go to London
(retro music)